hello and welcome to you're playing easy
engineer something like that oh that's a
remove 95 I guess okay I think C 3 and d
4 looks it looks right wow it's playing
instantly like this is a totally normal
position really odd what do you do here
probably D takes e5 other trends 25
winning we just totally ignored him okay
as usual the first the first move that
he spends more than one second on you
realize how it's lost
okay so let's see how to how to win this
most convincingly but should be three
probably or is then Knight takes Knight
takes d5 queen h7 check Bishop g5 now
that must be a window Bishop g5
with a shampoo and they're cancelling
next so what is quickest Knight takes
rook shakes
mmm it's a chick it doesn't doesn't
really matter for Bishop f6 if possible
yeah it's happening at Tech and end the
material
so let's trade off the only active piece
now Sam is coming
not much to look at him
you just blended everything basically in
the opening bishop before it's already a
little bit odd and that is not a fully
respectable move 95 96 and I think this
is correct
even though probably DeForrest better
now yeah the engine gives deform hmm
kind of suspected that I wasn't after
Syrian man what's that right this is
probably better I putting immediate
pressure on e5 if he takes it I have
five looks better for white I think this
is what I gave him my keep it simple
repertoire and why despair I was just a
bishop pair for search in an open
position ok c3 is not it's not a bad
move I guess d4 and now 90 fornix
already very dubious yeah maybe he has
to take I was intending to go 5 but the
engine actually think that black is fine
here okay Queenie 7 CD 46 possible yeah
I probably I should go here and this is
more powerful and the idea is oh I'm
going to be a little bit difficult
already I mean I'm threatening this and
you probably have to go d5 looks like it
looks sensible anyway and now I take and
I mean this position like that is just
going to be long-term suffering for
black in a symmetrical position you have
you don't have the bishop pair and you
have problems here on the dark squares
like here and the pawn we saw it sort of
course a lot better than this after the
after this is just a piece down form so
absolutely nothing black you should not
play Bishop before he if you want
something that is not the main line with
90 of 6 when it is the best move for a
g6 and Bishop c5 are somewhat playable
they are better for why
but they are not totally terrible if you
really want to avoid the absolute
symmetry it's not very not something you
can recommend you should go Knight f6
for our symmetry okay as thanks for
watching